[Music]
villanova takes on michigan tonight in
the men's championship game of the NCAA
basketball tournament Notre Dame won the
women's side of the tournament March
Madness is one of the most popular
events in American sports but critics of
the NCAA say while the school's run by
adults make billions of dollars the kids
who actually play don't get a cent in
real money of course not on Kevin cork
looks at that controversy tonight from
the hardwood to the college gridiron
great finishes in the NCAA are
commonplace the great finishes for the
athletes after the whistle stops are
increasingly rare mitch Daniels is the
former governor of the state of Indiana
and president at Purdue University we've
seen the game in essence
semi-professional eyes doll though the
people the young men who are creating
all the value don't get paid for it
something really needs to change daniels
is talking about the NCAA's labor force
which are the athletes themselves lured
by the promise of a possible education
while the NCAA generates billions an
imbalance that's garnered the attention
of the Congressional Black Caucus which
has announced a task force to assess the
treatment of student athletes including
the extent to which they are able to get
a college education including the
revenue that's generated by the student
athletes themselves we treat them as
employees without giving them the rights
that employees have david Ridpath is the
best-selling author on the subject of
sports and education we have to make a
choice are they students or are they
employees and they can't be both unlike
employees student athletes can't
collectively bargain and don't earn a
salary I know it sounds good on paper a
$200,000 education in return for playing
a sport that most people would play for
free I get that but the Devils in the
details today we announced charges of
fraud and corruption in the world of
college basketball details that have
attracted the attention of the FBI which
is investigating claims of bribery
impermissible gifts and even loans from
sports agents to players and their
families Brett member schools tell the
IRS
they're not for profit organizations
that emphasize academic excellence but
experts tell us that means unless
Congress does something to change the
system the NCAA will keep making big
bucks on the backs of its players right
all right Kevin thank you